good morning John yesterday I
interviewed the President of the United
States at the White House in Washington
DC
let's take a look at how my day went
Carolyn from my flight right now is
Obama gonna see the questions this this
is a Google employee so I'm gonna see
the questions before this happens nobody
in White House even on the president's
staff sees question these two people are
just basically my editorial consultants
to make sure that I don't say anything
truly dumb it's not all theater I'm
gonna surprise that man at least a
little bit I hope a little bit I
officially have an outfit Julie cuz well
did it well like you never I don't know
before she plugged the tag off I was
worried about hurting my pants you had
two people
how do people doesn't Roselle be
freezing in the White House I just like
to know it's cold
this is Frederick he's been playing
Obama and are in our rehearsals I have
hey-ho face it's like perfect so I just
came here the own balance I'm like
checking my teeth I just ate a cookie
all right I'm a pizza Bowie John shirt
on I'm getting ready to go to the White
House the problem with this is that we
now are gonna be at the White House for
like hours before this happens and I'm
gonna spend all that time panicking you
mind being on camera I'm getting
pampered now
we're on our final drive to the actual
White House for the actual interview
three hours to go these are very long
hours that's big White House now we're
in the independent holding pen between
two gates all right close I'm walking
and breathed on the grass like that's
wrong feeling set now because we were oh
yeah this looks exactly like the other
room except much nicer we're having a
pre visit from some ambassadors I
recognize there's a lot anticipation in
this video that's because there's a lot
of anticipation in this process in the
White House I can't figure out how to
turn on the lights presidential
interview brought to you by imodium a-d
Secret Service just came in it was very
obvious that they were Secret Service I
just noticed that this this glass is
very very thick I've been told that
there's a helicopter it's going to land
right there
so he got on a helicopter to come see me
final bathroom break for the thing or
taking my camera which means it's really
real now so I have to go hey great to
see a President Obama thank you so much
Brad thanks a lot for doing it it's cool
I don't really feel like I'm having you
this is your house it's the people's
house I'm actually leasing and my lease
runs out in two years all right
it did it did tap it I'm gonna take this
I'm also gonna take this copy of tippy
O's because it's mine now I did it it's
over I can go to sleep I can't now I
have to talk to press I don't mean to
brag but I've got an ear thing all right
I did it
I wonder what Hillary thinks by White
House thanks bye that one's locked - I'm
having Cuban sandwich at an American
restaurant Josh Sundquist I'm back in
Florida now dad and Kathleen just picked
me up at the airport oh hey thanks for
turning the light on how'd I do
amazing what would you have said if I
had done terribly amazing I got a good
night's sleep I had a dream that I was a
road I'm feeling good now I gotta edit
the video Thank You druthers good job
I'm so proud of you you hear awesome it
was so great is that the copy the folder
started president touch it is John I'll
see you on Friday that's today because
it's right now